der keller einer ehemaligen bankfiliale
in der kleinen stadt kaarst in nordrhein
westfalen für viele geflüchtete aus der
ukraine ist es ihre erste anlaufstelle
freiwillige betreuen jeden tag und 100
menschen natalia ist mit ihren zwei
kindern aus kiel vor dem krieg geflohen
seit drei wochen sind sie in kaarst
ich möchte den freiwilligen hier von
ganzem herzen danke sagen sie helfen uns
bei der ersten integration
wir kennen uns ja alle wir bekommen
ratschläge sie wissen an wen wir uns
wenden sollen mit unseren papieren und
sie geben und sogar kleidung
viele geflüchtete sind angewiesen auf
die unterstützung übersetzen von
dokumenten beantragen von
sozialleistungen die suche nach einer
wohnung ohne die helfer wären sie in der
deutschen bürokratie verloren erzählen
die ukrainerinnen doch auch die die
helfen haben zu kämpfen ja die stimmung
unter den freiwilligen ist eigentlich
langsam eine ermüdende stimmung wir
machen das jetzt hier seit ungefähr
sechs wochen und zu anfang war natürlich
waren die leute sehr motiviert es wird
etwas weniger das normale leben holt ein
auch ein wie lange sie noch durchhalten
offen
es wäre natürlich schön wenn irgendwo
eine institution stadt land fluss wo ihr
auch immer hingehen und sagt so hier ist
eine initiative die ist gut die wollen
wir unterstützen
da könnt gelder fließen als dass wir uns
überlegen müssen okay wie sieht es in
zwei wochen aus können wir überhaupt das
angebot noch so bereitstellen oder
fahren wir es sowieso runter in vielen
städten sieht es ähnlich aus helfer und
geflüchtete kommen an ihre grenzen dabei
hatte bundeskanzler olaf scholz einen
großen wunsch formuliert
ich wünsche mir dass wir uns schnell und
zügig einigen zwischen dem bund den
ländern dass wir die interessen der
kommunen und landkreise hier
berücksichtigen damit wir uns der
eigentlichen aufgaben zuwenden können
wir helfen wir den flüchtlingen die hier
schutz gesucht haben der bund hat
ländern und kommunen zusätzlich zwei
milliarden euro für unterbringung und
versorgung der geflüchteten versprochen
bürgermeisterin ursula baum sagt in
kaarst sei von dem geld bisher nichts
angekommen 400 geflüchtete musste die
stadt bisher versorgen das ist teuer
dazu kommt die einzige
flüchtlingsunterkunft in kaarst ist voll
deshalb muss die kommune baldauf
turnhallen ausweichen
wir haben ja so schon keine wohnungen
also auch in cars ist das ein
riesenproblem
sozialwohnungen zu finden das können wir
nur noch auf eigenen städtischen
grundstücken in gewisser weise
veranlassen das tun wir auch immer wir
bauen eine gewisse größe immer sozial
auch mit das denken wir schon mit aber
es ist einfach nicht ausreichend
nun muss eine turnhalle erreichen
wir haben hauptsächlich mütter mit
kindern und da habe ich eine ganz klare
meinung ich möchte eigentlich nicht dass
ein kind in einer turnhalle cruz will
bisher sind fast alle geflüchteten in
kaarst privat bei familien untergekommen
wie bei den schäfers sie haben vor
einigen wochen marina aus der nähe von
kiew bei sich aufgenommen für die
gastfamilie eine selbstverständlichkeit
ich versetze mich einfach in deren lagen
es könnte uns auch vielleicht treffen
und dann stehen wir da mit zwei kindern
und wissen nicht wohin von daher ist es
glaube ich echt echt furchtbar
marina dürfe so lange bleiben wie sie
möchte sorgen um eine unterkunft muss
sie sich vorerst nicht machen weil
familien einspringen wo der staat nicht
hinterherkommt wenn die privaten
familien nicht wären würde das glaube
ich ein ziemlich großes chaos geben
berlin auch hier sind es freiwillige die
dem staat unter die arme greifen der
verein moabit hilft betreut täglich etwa
300 hilfsbedürftige vor allem aus der
ukraine elena und cristina sind anfang
märz nach deutschland geflohen jetzt
leben sie im flüchtlingsheim und stecken
fest im deutschen amtshaus
wir haben nicht erwartet dass das hier
alles so extrem bürokratisch ist so wie
es gibt es schon viel bürokratie aber
hier ist das noch schlimmer
dabei wurde uns erklärt dass für uns
schon ausnahmen gemacht werden und alles
schneller läuft als üblich
die freiwilligen verteilen lebensmittel
kleidung und hygieneartikel
[Musik]
ich warte seit einem monat auf einen
termin beim amt für migration und meine
dokumente habe ich bereits online
eingereicht doch gehört habe ich noch
nichts
ich bin zwei monate hier bekommen noch
immer keine sozialhilfe und habe keinen
cent die gründerin von moabit hilft
berät täglich menschen aus der ukraine
und weiß warum viele geflüchtete an den
deutschen behörden scheitern und
verzweifelt
das landesamt für einwanderung das
eigentlich seit jahren sagt das
unterfinanzierte dass es da mehr geld
braucht damit ihn vernünftig arbeiten
können die digitalisierung dieser ganzen
prozesse dem steht ein ich aus es fällt
immer alles zusammen die ganzen server
sind eigentlich immer stetig überlastet
und das auch bevor in der ukraine der
krieg ausbrach
die ministerpräsidenten der länder und
die bundesregierung reagieren spät sechs
wochen nach kriegsbeginn ab juni sollen
ukrainische geflüchtete komplett aus
einer hand betreut werden und zwar von
den jobcentern der bundesagentur für
arbeit
mir war war dabei besonders wichtig dass
wir gerade für unsere kommunen eine
schnelle und faire lösung mit einer
deutlichen entlastung finden
der landkreis dachau
1500 geflüchtete müssen sie hier
versorgen und dieser mann soll es jetzt
richten peter schade der chef des
jobcenters
auf peter schade warten zahlreiche
aufgaben
er soll arbeitslosengeld 2 an die
geflüchteten auszahlen und eine bessere
medizinische versorgung ermöglichen
schade jobcenter übernimmt zudem die
kosten für unterbringung und verpflegung
der soll auch deutschkurse organisieren
und bei der arbeitsvermittlung und der
anerkennung von berufsabschlüssen helfen
konkret bedeutet das hunderte anträge
bearbeiten tausende gespräche führen
doch anfangen kann er nicht denn das
nötige gesetz ist noch gar nicht fertig
es bleiben vier wochen die knackpunkte
könnten sein dass die ukrainische
flüchtlinge tatsächlich die
leidtragenden sind weil der gesetzgeber
ein gutes gesetz machen will aber wir
nicht genügend vorlaufzeit den nötigen
ressourcen bekommen gilt personal
vollmer aber auch zeit die
bundespressekonferenz am vergangenen
montag frontal fragt nach beim sprecher
des bundesarbeitsministeriums
wir sind derzeit in der vorbereitung ja
es bedarf einer rechtlichen umsetzung
das werden wir schnellstmöglichst
vornehmen und das wird auch nicht mehr
lange dauern die jobcenter sagen uns die
brauchen mindestens vier wochen vorlauf
um das überhaupt organisatorisch über
die bühne zu bringen wie wollen sie denn
sicherstellen dass die leute dann ab
juni auch wirklich ein geld kommt also
sie können sich sicher sein dass die
jobs sind da schon im vorfeld da
eingebunden sind und entsprechende
vorkehrungen treffen können und wir
setzen natürlich alles daran dass dieses
auch möglichst
einwandfreie dann auch umgesetzt wird
einwandfrei umgesetzt und im vorfeld
eingebunden im jobcenter in dachau
jedenfalls haben sie davon bisher wenig
mitbekommen wissen sie denn überhaupt
schon lange im wasser was da drin stehen
könnte leider nein
der community garden in dachau spielen
und toben ablenken vom krieg doch bei
vielen deutschen helfern ist der frust
groß über die versprechen der politik
und das was bisher daraus geworden ist
das heißt ich habe jetzt privat mein
schlafzimmer hergegeben und kann
irgendwie schauen wie ich für die für
meinen gast auch eine perspektive
schaffe und ja ich bin vielleicht ein
sehr realistischer pragmatischer mensch
aber ich sehe da noch ziemliche dramen
auf uns zukommt